joining me now is dr ben carson former
housing and urban development
secretary dr carson your reaction
today's
executive actions and susan rice's
announcement of them
well it's pretty amazing uh how people
try to
frame everything uh racially and how
they
uh create the visions among our society
you know i grew up in the 50s and 60s
and i can tell you
what real racism was like it was an
everyday event
the world is very different here in
america right now
and you know to use race as a mechanism
to obtain
power and position i think is really
quite shameful
and in fact race relationships have
deteriorated
why have they deteriorated because of
the great emphasis
trying to create white guilt and black
victimhood
those are two very bad things and when
you put them together
it results in some policies that
absolutely make no sense
so the the real uh conflict here
is between common sense and idiots
idiocy
that's what's really going on now on pbs
tonight
responding to the criticisms of the
biden executive action
susan rice said this it's a bit rich
frankly for republicans to suggest that
by trying to lift up
everybody we are dividing america we
just had four years of the most divisive
uh vitriolic uh presidency that that
one can imagine um and that the division
was a political strategy
and thankfully it hasn't worked because
it is not what the american people want
dr carson not only record low
unemployment
record wage growth and criminal justice
reform
uh community uh engagement with
uh new investment and inner city
an attempt to reach out yeah opportunity
zones
none of it none of it registers because
they don't want it to register
yeah well they're they're saying don't
believe your eyes
just believe what we're telling you and
you are a victim
and these people are oppressing you and
i appeal to the american people
to stop listening to the foolishness
and use your brain and believe what you
see
and what you feel you know america is
full of very good people the vast
majority
of americans are decent individuals they
will extend
a helping hand to anyone who is in need
including their neighbors
they don't ask if you're a democrat or
republican
but we have a political class and a
media
that does nothing but specialize in
stirring up
anger and stirring up resentment and i
guess that makes them feel powerful and
makes them feel needed
i would appeal to them to maybe listen
to their better angels
you know this is a time when we can make
tremendous progress everybody's talking
about unity and working together
let's actually do that we create our own
problems
and we are going to be the ones who
destroy this country if we continue to
listen to the purveyors
of division and hatred it's in our hands
the people
one of biden's executive orders
secretary carson took
aim at federal housing policy of course
you used to be in charge of that watch
housing
is a right in america and home ownership
is an essential tool
to wealth creation and to be passed down
to generations
today i'm directing the department of
housing and urban affairs and urban
development
to redress historical racism and federal
housing policies
dr carson uh do you feel he's attacking
you directly in that statement
uh well i don't i don't feel attacked
because i think we made a tremendous
amount of progress in that area
recognized that the majority of
discrimination cases in housing
had nothing to do with race it had to do
with disabilities
we're very concerned about housing and
have
removed many of the obstacles
particularly for minorities
because it's the primary mechanism for
wealth creation in this country
the average home owner is worth two
hundred thousand dollars average renter
is worth five thousand dollars
obviously we want to change that dynamic
we need to work on the policies that
will allow that to be done
and i hope that this administration
rather than feeling the need to point
fingers
will utilize some of the gains that we
made
capitalize upon those and make more
progress well raising energy prices
which is what's happening now you
probably noticed uh what's happening at
the pumps but
that's going to be a big added cost to
most people especially
on the lower ends of the economic ladder
it's horrific dr carson great to see you
tonight
and that's that's well let me just say
that's an area where we need to make
progress
and common sense because we say we have
to have these solar panels
and yet if you open a solar panel what's
in there copper
and other kinds of elements that they're
trying to suppress
through the department of interior makes
no sense
dr carson thanks so much